una victoria amplia pero insuficiente
likud el partido del primer ministro
benjamin netanyahu ganó las elecciones
parlamentarias de israel pero la
formación de un gobierno aún no está
garantizada un escenario de paridad
repetido en un país que ha celebrado
cuatro elecciones en dos años
netanyahu llamó a salir de la
incertidumbre
el país necesita un gobierno estable no
uno hecho corones basado en rechazos y
ambiciones personales y no debemos
arrastrar al estado de israel a una
nueva elección
una quinta elección hay que formar un
gobierno estable ahora con el respaldo
garantizado de ultraortodoxos y
ultraconservadores un futuro ejecutivo
liderado por netanyahu podría depender
de yamina una alianza de partidos de
derecha y ultraderecha su líder se
mostró abierto a una gran coalición
derechista estoy decidido a promover los
valores de la derecha en cualquier
gobierno que se ha formado voy a actuar
bajo un solo principio lo que es bueno
para israel
listo del
por su parte los partidos de oposición
de ideologías diversas lograron mejores
resultados de lo esperado y el líder de
la segunda fuerza más votada asegura que
podrían formar un gobierno que fomente
los diálogos con los líderes del bloque
del cambio por supuesto continuaremos
hablando en los próximos días vamos a
esperar a los resultados finales pero
haremos todo para crear un gobierno sano
en el estado de israel
la participación en los comicios ha sido
la más baja desde 2013 una señal del
cansancio de la población ante la
inestabilidad política
los resultados definitivos no se
conocerían hasta el viernes y a partir
de entonces comenzará la lucha por
formar un gobierno en caso contrario el
país podría dirigirse a una quinta
elección